euh le design de l'expérience
utilisateur qui est entièrement centré
sur l'algorithme de recommandation et on
va dire avec une vidéo à la fois et ça
c'est assez ça vient dans la continuité
d'une tendance qui existe sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis plusieurs années
mais où sont nés ou en fait si on pense
au premier film Facebook par exemple qui
était en fait le premier endroit où on a
vraiment un fil de recommandation
algorithmique qui va être définir ce qui
est consommé par par l'utilisateur à une
grande échelle on commence on avait
typiquement faire un écran d'ordinateur
5 ou 6 postes visibles à n'importe quel
moment ce qui donnait tout de même une
certaine liberté de choix pour
l'utilisateur de savoir où est-ce qu'il
allait concentrer son attention
le passage sur mobile a déjà eu tendance
aussi à réduire cette quantité
d'information présente à un instant T
sur l'écran d'un utilisateur on voit que
sur Twitter sur Facebook sur Youtube
partout on a une tendance à augmenter la
taille des potes pour en avoir de moins
en moins et donc un algorithme quelque
part de plus en plus paternaliste qui va
décider pour l'utilisateur ce qu'on va
regarder et TikTok c'est entre
guillemets la forme la plus extrême de
cette tendance où on a une vidéo à la
fois et ça ça a deux conséquences déjà
ça la conséquence de diminuer la charge
cognitive pour l'utilisateur c'est à
dire que d'un coup on a même plus besoin
de se demander qu'est-ce qu'on va
regarder on a juste à Swiper un peu à la
on a aussi sans doute une inspiration de
de tinder quoi vous fait vraiment j'aime
pas mais je réfléchis pas trop et ça va
très vite
et l'autre conséquence que ça
c'est que ça va permettre à l'algorithme
d'avoir une quantité de données
d'entraînement qui est bien supérieur à
celle des autres plateformes et d'une
qualité aussi bien supérieure parce que
pour chacune de ces vidéos qui vont être
évaluées par l'utilisateur c'est-à-dire
toutes les 5 ou 10 secondes en la
regardant en entier ou en passant à la
suivante on va avoir un point de données
d'entraînement pour savoir si la vidéo
en question correspond à son intérêt ou
pas et donc là où en une heure de
visionnage de YouTube on va regarder
peut-être une dizaine de vidéos et donc
fournir une dizaine de points
d'entraînement à la plateforme sur
TikTok en une heure on va donner
plusieurs centaines voire un millier de
points de donner d'entraînement qui vont
ensuite pouvoir permettre de déterminer
les intérêts niches de de l'utilisateur